my colleague from the nfl media group
one of my favorite people in all the
land ian rappaport at rap sheet for to
follow him back here in the rich eisen
show how are you ian
what's going on rich how are you i'm
feeling good man i'm like i feel i've
been i've been i've been you know
eager to sit back in this chair and here
i am and i appreciate you joining me on
my first show back thank you appreciate
it
i would there's nowhere else i'd rather
be i mean i'm literally where i usually
am
but i'm just saying
by the way that's that that's the longer
version of what i guess what marv levy
used to say where would you rather be
than right here where you usually are
sitting like that doesn't have the same
ring to it you know what i'm saying i
feel motivated anyway go ahead
okay
now you've been at this a long time
you've been there you've done that have
you ever heard of a precautionary mri
before you know just to stick yourself
in that tube just to see what's what
just to make sure you're you're you're
feeling good about yourself or what what
is going on with dak prescott right now
i actually have you have heard of
something
i have many many many times
and
this is all so normal the fact that
everyone treated it as not normal
i was like
fairly surprised when i saw the tweet
that the um
the tweet that the cowboys themselves
put out yeah and it was like oh i get it
now i understand why everyone freaked
out because
their tweet was basically the equivalent
of like hey no offense but and you're
like whoa why did you just defend me
they were like don't freak out it's all
normal jack's getting an mri and i'm
like
now i have to freak out like it was
it was i mean it was ridiculous but um i
also know that the cowboys twitter
account much like a website or not run
by the football people they kind of have
their own mind so i get it okay um that
is going to be okay he really is it
really is precautionary it really is
non-structural he really is going to be
fine
why are they consulting the yankees and
the rangers then what's that all about
is that precautionary um
yeah i mean the yankees and the rangers
thing i thought was kind of interesting
mainly because dak has a pitcher's
injury like it feels like like if you if
you kind of put your hands
probably like six inches under your
underarm that's kind of where it seems
like the injury is
um which is
i feel like a
sort of follow-through pitcher injury
rather than a quarterback injury is just
not something they they see all the time
if you have access to
good medical sources like a good cowboys
people do okay um then consult them and
you know it
makes sense it's due diligence uh it is
a quarterback so freaking out is
expected and okay
but deck really is gonna be fine okay so
dak is gonna be your week one starter
let's just all just uh take the old
proverbial uh chill pill he's gonna be
the week one starter
um and uh is it
is there anything going on with jalen
smith
ian what's going on with him well
i would not say nothing is going on i
don't know what the cowboys are gonna do
i will say that
um but
the sort of recent online chatter it's
kind of similar to what to what where it
was last year except
you know jalen smith i think at one
point the cowboys really thought he
deserved a big extension if you thought
he was going to be a star linebacker
then their extension at the time made a
lot of sense obviously struggled last
year you hope that in the
you know i'm not it's not a new scheme
this year it's actually but stan quinsky
but it's what they ran two years ago so
it's jalen is familiar with it you sort
of hoped that he'd be back to the
linebacker that deserved the big
extension
problem is
kean o'neal
uh has played great now health has sort
of been a concern for him but
um he's basically a linebacker now he's
fast he has been a baller dan quinn
loves him so if you have michael parsons
leighton van der esque who's had a
really good camp and you have kean
o'neill on the field
paying seven million dollars to someone
who's not among your top three
linebackers is not a great use of
resources you know for the cowboys it
would be admitting a mistake
but it's better than compounding one so
i i wouldn't if you were wondering like
is releasing jalen smith
something that at least may be talked
about yeah i think it's something they
may talk about ian rappaport here on the
rich eisen show what's going on with
desean watson what is happening with him
with the texans and
and then other teams or the
commissioner's office so what is
happening with him
you know he's practicing in individuals
and then going inside uh and then he's
not thrilled with reporters for videoing
the same thing every day that's
basically the synopsis here um
you know the league office has been very
very very clear
they
they're looking into it they're
investigating they're going to let the
police and whatever other investigation
take its course but they are looking
into it they have
sports illustrated said they have
interviewed
a couple of the accusers
um
the commissioner's exempt list is
basically for as it states
someone who they have evidence of
committed a violent crime
that is what the rules are that is what
they now they could always go back and
say
we're going to change it a little bit i
mean they have been known to tinker from
time to time
but that is what it's for
uh desean watson does not fit that
criteria
so
as of now
he's
eligible to play he seems to be he does
not have the texans in his plans of
playing they do not seem to be preparing
him to play this season
so unless something changes they're
really only two options he gets put on
ice for the entire season pays 10
million dollars to do nothing or because
he said he's not going to play for them
or
at some point over the next couple weeks
they trade him i haven't sensed
any like huge momentum to a trade but
if a trade like this happens it's going
to be very fast and probably very secret
so i wouldn't rule anything out so then
um
in terms of that speculation um
obviously all eyes on philadelphia um
and there's a couple of moving parts on
that and variables one of them being
jalen hurts and how he performs what are
you hearing about
his first uh performance of the
preseason and what nick ciriani and the
rest of the front office with harry
roseman thinking about that scenario
right now sounded like it was pretty
good you know i mean he didn't have uh
devante smith but i mean it it looked
pretty good and it sounded like the
reviews were pretty good you know the
interesting thing about
about him is you don't quite know what
he is
right like we saw him in college from a
couple different colleges we've seen
jalen hurts adam field last year at the
end and definitely had some moments um
certainly helped bring me to a fantasy
title which i don't think should go into
their evaluations
but in my heart it's something i will
always appreciate my first fantasy title
you never forget that it's still a
metric ian it's still a metric maybe not
to front offices but it to you it is and
i i respect it i respect it i mean it
was
that was certainly a great moment in my
household anyway but um
i don't know what he is i mean to me he
kind of reminds me of young
dak prescott where
there's plenty of people who judge that
he's not a franchise guy because he
doesn't
look and play like what people
generally older people think is a
franchise guy
but people need to look again and
obviously for dak it worked out and will
continue to work out
i could see jalen going in a similar
direction like he's got some of the same
attributes where he creates his own
opportunities because of the way he
moves and looks to throw like that is
really that is really valuable um anyway
it sounds like the returns early on were
pretty good well and the other variable
in this is something that won't be
finalized before the season begins and
that's how many first-round draft
choices
philadelphia has next year and part of
that is how many games carson wentz
winds up playing
um he and quentin nelson having the
dreaded five to twelve week injury is it
what are you hearing about that because
i'm i'm hearing or reading uh quite a
bit that that it could be on that five
week end of things and that wentz and
nelson both have an opportunity to be
seen in week one what are you hearing on
that front yeah i mean i don't think
anyone's ruled out week one and the fact
that they're at practice without a
walking boot
um
is you know the first like couple days
is good it's all good it sounds like the
surgeries went well basically for carson
wentz
um they essentially extracted a bone
from his foot that had i guess come
loose which you know if you're squeamish
not a great thing to think about nope
um i would not want anyone to extract
any of my bones
um but that's what it was and it sounds
like rehab you know rest is going great
we don't know if he's going to be ready
week one and it was extremely important
what jim merced said on the
uh i think he said it on the tv
broadcast this weekend which is that we
are not going to put carson once out
there if he's not healthy wence wants to
play i think he was out there too early
with the eagles
he played through some stuff that ended
up being detrimental to him
uh remember he was out there week three
and probably didn't look like himself i
mean just he always wants to play
it's a 17 game season you might have
heard a little bigger than usual
um it is important that the culture
protect him from himself
so if he's not out there week one it'll
be soon but i do think you're looking at
the early end not the 12 weekend okay
and then obviously when you're talking
about a bone being removed from a foot i
mean
yikes um
what is the the so is the plan to just
go
with eason and ellinger and
and
and hope for the best just in case it
goes longer or
best you could tell has there been a
phone call made to a high school coach
in alabama and phillip rivers to see
what he's doing or
foals is obviously the lost man in
chicago like what what is the those
moving parts on that front well rivers
has a season to coach so i think he was
pretty clear that you know high school
football is the most important thing
which is hilarious but then again at the
alabama high school football they take
it extremely serious right um and he's
had this job in his mind and hearts for
like 10 years so i imagine he's
in all seriousness too ian i mean he
probably has you know when you're a
coach you give a commitment to a team um
and to look at look a high school kid in
the face and say yeah i got to go i got
to go take this job in indianapolis but
i'll be back you know
that you know that's that's probably why
he was also saying you know if the phone
rings in november and december when he's
done with the the season he might
consider it you know
but um
he would blame him no not like
you know he's got he's got a team to
coach correct so but but but
you know still though the colts could
still make the call i'm just i'm just
trying to see here like it is quite a
you know
uh a safety net that you would be either
stitching or without
you know with wence going into the
season with uh whence iffy to come back
sometime soon with an injury that who
knows a complication could occur week
two week three what happens
you know like that's what i mean
i think the main issue there's two
issues here one the colts don't want to
spend an asset you know let's say it's a
minute you're not going to trade for a
quarterback that would start for you
without giving up some sort of mid-round
pick so
do you want is it worth doing that for
one game or two games i would say
probably not the other thing is look at
the way the culture constructed i mean
they are a draft and developed team
they hate spending free agency ask any
agent ballard knows
um hates spending in free agency they
don't
trade for a ton of guys unless they
absolutely have to like with jacoby
brissette
they liked they're like their own guys
they like to see what their own guys
have and so
for a lot of teams i would kind of roll
my eyes if they're like yeah we're not
looking at a trade right now the colts i
believe it because that is part of their
core
so like if it's not jacob eason could it
be sam ellinger like yeah i mean it
really could be for a game or two
a few more minutes left with ian rap
report my colleague from the nfl media
group here on the rich eisen show what's
the scoop with tua you know all the
whispers involving him and
his readiness to be a pro and a starter
and all of that business um well what
what do you got for me on on that front
um because that's the other team that
everybody's
associated with right you know uh
deshawn watson wanderlust what do you
got for me on that right now as it
stands i think you know tua has uh
steadily come along his camp i would
describe is pretty good
they're getting him to come out of
himself a little bit so push the ball
down the field take some chances
you know he tried to do that in the end
zone end up throwing interception where
he really just saw the tight end i
believe it was a little bit too late
but that's almost okay like they want
him to take chances they want him to
push it deep they want him to kind of do
what he did at alabama which is let it
go like let it lose
so i think his camp has been good you
know is he going to develop into the
superstar franchise quarterback some
thought i don't know but they definitely
think he can be a more than solid
franchise starter which is
you know for a team that
is going to have a really good defense
like that's okay um i don't know how
high a ceiling is going to be
but you know it if they go into the
season with two as their starter and he
starts 17 games i believe the dolphins
are going to be absolutely fine okay and
the last one for you it's remarkable
here we are one week into the preseason
and the rogers packers story is
uh essentially put to bed
for 2021 we'll see what happens when
games start to be played
and and what have you but um i i guess
he spoke to our colleague peter king and
even left the door open to continue on
here um which does not surprise me one
bit um i mean why would anybody want to
start
going somewhere else late in the career
you want to stay put certainly if you've
got a championship team surrounding you
in a community that you
feel comfortable in uh what do you think
of uh where we stand on that subject
matter
right now well um you're kind of right i
mean it's which i know is what you're
going for um
it uh always ian yes thank you yeah
always um
it's basically
put i won't say put to bed but
definitely put on ice i thought the the
stuff from peter king rogers to peter
king
um
was was pretty interesting
you know because one he did sort of
leave the door open for a relationship
with godicans
he definitely didn't sound like some we
wanted to play in green bay and then
that's it remember the biggest one of
the biggest points for rogers was he
didn't want to be a lame duck
quarterback and if that's true
then it definitely sounds like he's open
to playing in green bay
oh there he goes there he goes is he
back is he back are you there ian
are you there explain what just happened
i don't know what just happened i i
don't know but i need i i was excited
exactly i explained to my audience i've
solved the issue okay i i just my wife
pulled my wife pulled in she was out she
pulled into the garage bluetooth my
bluetooth picked up on her car oh my god
automatic automatic do you want to know
what do you know what she was saying
about you now you know
unfortunately she could only hear me
detailing the aaron rodgers
[Laughter]
i'm sure she's used to that but i'll
sure just uh just uh let me know what uh
what you were continuing your thoughts
here that there's uh
an openness that so i get look i i i'm
thrilled that there's an openness and
that he's
i think woe to the rest of the nfc if he
is gonna show up you know calm cool
collected as well as he has and just zen
and totally you know jupiter's aligned
with mars and he's going to bring the
the same game that he brought to saving
dechambeau's bacon in montana to the nfc
i mean that's a that's a problem for
everyone else i fully believe i thought
he played great by the way
he's a much better golfer than i
anticipated
he's actually like a three and a half
handicap which i'm so jealous of but
anyway
um
i think the the openness to potentially
come back and finish his career there
assuming they want him there
was really interesting to me that was
definitely a driving force for this and
the other thing is he is dialed in like
i don't think we're gonna be
i don't think he's gonna get to a post
game press conference talk about not
feeling loved this season i mean maybe
we'll get to this again during the trade
deadline we'll see if the packers do
something
but
i mean it he's at least there for the
season with an openness and a directness
that he
may not have had in the past right i
think i think they're in a good spot
especially since
the guy that they want to potentially
move on from uh can't might not be able
to even answer the preseason week two
bell i mean and this guy is right as as
i mean it's all it's it's all
good in the hood there and i just think
it's remarkable based on how much we
talked about it from draft day all the
way to you know reunification day for
him and the team so
i just figured i'd bring that up thanks
for the time ian rappaport go say hi to
your wife for us
okay
now the channel uh i will and i'm i'm
really curious to see what uh part of
the conversation she heard and what she
thought of my opinion
there you go
there you go pleased to text me now we
also got closures
i feel so much better
saying goodbye to ian wrap now thanks
for the call thank you rap sheet the man
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here